yes you gave code geoff season one of
ten and
code your season two and eight oh what
are your thoughts on that okay
okay okay i'm interested okay i've okay
so i
i remember giving it a 10. okay so the
thing about code yes right
is i gave it a 10 the first time i
watched it because i thought it was like
a [ __ ] masterpiece it was perfect it
was everything
uh i recently uh not recently like i
really watched cody's with sydney
and there was a lot of flaws in season
one that i guess i just
kind of ignored as a kid or just like
you kind of forgot about yeah
like okay like i remember re-watching it
and i'm just like
why is there an episode dedicated to
chasing a cat and how did i just blank
this from my memory
like that episode was very [ __ ]
like in my interview because i remember
first watching kogiyas it was like easy
10 out of 10. this is like
the greatest anime can become and i
think i just remember the good points of
code gears because there was a lot of
like
plot holes and everything like it's how
can we spoil code geass
yeah i think i think it's you know we're
going to small cookies okay i thought
it's universally
it's okay it's like skip to this skip to
this time stamp below because cody us if
you haven't watched code guess and you
want to watch it okay
it's one of the most spoilable shows um
out there but i
i remember re-watching it and i'm just
like man they they really
they really had to like twist the plot
in order to make
nina or what was not nina um euphemia
just [ __ ] massacre
everyone right right because because i
remember watching it i'm just thinking
man the plot's kind of over now
everything's sorted and it was just
it was just the most racism is over
everyone go home it was just the most
roundabout way
of like okay guys we're going to make
the plot continue how can we make the
plot continue
and it was literally it was it was
literally a scene where lelouch goes
ha ha wouldn't it be funny if i told you
to kill the japanese
haha psych x and and then then it wasn't
it did happen right
yeah and like and like i just i just
remembered
thinking wow i remember thinking as a
kid that was a huge plot twist and now
watching is
watching as an adult i'm just like this
is stupid i'm just like
this kind of this kind of doesn't make
sense this this is kind of pretty pretty
cheap right there this is pretty cheap
writing
yeah um so yeah like i would now i would
give code geass
season one maybe an eight i think
because the highs of code geos are so
good
yeah like you you almost forgive it the
highs are very high so you like you
forgive it for a lot of the [ __ ] it does
yeah yeah
and then season two was like that was
that was
i don't know what it is about season two
that was like a car crash that somehow
yeah season two was a car crash that
somehow perfectly parallel parked
like
it was it was like absolute disaster and
somehow it like just
landed it landed its ending perfectly
and i remember re-watching cody's r2
after season one and i and aft going on
the problems i had with season one
season two just took all the like small
problems with season one and just
extrapolated to them
so like let's take every stupid every
stupid plot twist in season one and just
make it ten times bigger
true true and i think the the exact
moment that lost me in season two was
like it was it was lelouch it was the
i am you know i am spartacine but just
with lelouch
and i just thought okay this this is not
this is not cleverly yeah it's just
stupid
and everything up to that till like the
final three episodes was [ __ ] dumb
but they just they stick the landing man
but like the ending
is still i think the best ending
ever in that stop there yeah i i i i
would think
i'd agree with that i would think it's
probably the best of the top my head the
best ending anime has produced
so far so god is that an unpopular
opinion
god no god knows god knows